# OpenAIは復権したのか？
自社半導体ハラペーニョとは何か？
メンバーシップの新着記事が届きました。
noteで読むことができます。
オープンエーアイは復権したのか？
自社半導体ハラペーニョとは何か？
誰が儲かるのか？
ことしの5月から6月頃から、オープンエーアイが復権の兆しを感じている人は多いのではなかろうか。
「Codexに戻ってきてしまった」「ジーピーティー5.6、結構いい」「Claudeよりコスパいい」といった投稿が、また目につくようになってきました。
つい7月から8月ヶ月前まで、タイムラインは「Geminiの時代で決まった」「ChatGPTはオワコン」「解約してClaudeに乗り換えた」という声で埋め尽くされていたのが、うそのようです。
事実、2025年から2026年初頭まで、オープンエーアイを取り巻く数字は散々でした。
6月に米調査会社センサータワーが発表した調査では、対話型エーアイ全体におけるChatGPTのシェアはついに50パーセントを割り込んで46パーセントとなり、1年で13ポイントも下落したんです。
Geminiはグーグル検索とAndroidを武器にシェアを2割まで伸ばし、アンソロピックに至っては、2026年3月時点で年換算売上がオープンエーアイを追い越したことまで判明しました。
ゆな先生も春の記事で、アンソロピックの異常な躍進と、その裏でグーグルがボロ儲けする構造について解説しました。
オープンエーアイは明らかに停滞していたんです。
ジーピーティー5のずっこけから続く、王者の凋落ですね。
ところが、である。
2026年の夏に入ってから、景色が明らかに変わりました。
8月6日、オープンエーアイは「毎週10億人がChatGPTを使っている」と公式に発表しました。
週間アクティブユーザー10億人。
地球の8人に1人が、毎週ChatGPTを叩き起こしている計算です。
開発者界隈では、あれほどClaude Code一色だったタイムラインに「Codex回帰」の投稿が増え、法人界隈でもChatGPT Workの導入報告が流れてくるようになりました。
王者の復権です。
なぜ、あれほどオワコン扱いされていたChatGPTが、2026年中盤から巻き返しているのか。
そしてもう一つ。
6月24日、オープンエーアイは半導体大手Broadcomと共同開発した、同社初の独自設計エーアイチップ「Jalapeño（ハラペーニョ）」を発表しました。
ゆな先生は激辛料理はあまり好きではないのでハラペーニョを食べるのは無理なのですが、この激辛香辛料のような名前のチップは、Nvidiaのジーピーユーより電力あたりの仕事量で1.5倍から1.9倍という良さそうなベンチマークまで公開されているんです。
だが、このnoteの読者のみなさんなら知っているはずですが、半導体というのは、チップが完成してから本当に使い物になるまでが長いんです。
グーグルのティーピーユーですら、10年前からかいはつをしています。
では、ハラペーニョは、ライブラリやソフトウェアの整備まで含めて考えたとき、実質的にいつから本格的に使われていくのか。
きょうはこの2つを、分析していきましょう。
オープンエーアイはどうなるのか？
自社半導体はどうなるのか？
その答えは…
まず答えとして、ジーピーティー復権の正体は、一発逆転のスーパーモデルでもなく、物量と開発リリース速度の賜物であること。
そしてハラペーニョが実質的に主力として稼働し始めるのは2027年後半から2028年、しかも主役は今回発表された初代ではなく、すでに開発終盤にある第2世代だとゆな先生は見ています。
それでは見ていきましょう。
## 復権の第一要因はモデルの世代交代ラッシュ
まずさいしょの要因は、シンプルにモデルが強くなったことです。
ただし、強くなり方が去年までとはまるで違うんです。
2025年のオープンエーアイを思い出してほしい。
鳴り物入りで投入されたジーピーティー5がずっこけて、性能でGeminiに抜かれ、コーディングでClaudeに完敗し、王者の看板が音を立てて剥がれ落ちていきました。
あの頃のオープンエーアイは、一発逆転の特大ホームランを狙って大振りし、空振りしていたんです。
2025年は圧倒的にGeminiの年でした。
ところが2026年のオープンエーアイは、野球で考えるとバッターとしてのスタイルを完全に変えてきた感じになりました。
ホームランを捨てて、6週間ごとに単打を積み重ねる野球です。
時系列で並べてみましょう。
2026年3月3日、日常利用の中核となるジーピーティー5.3 Instantが投入されました。
売りは賢さではなく、過剰に丁寧で説教臭いエーアイ特有の文体の抑制と、ハルシネーションの低減です。
その2日後の3月5日には推論特化のジーピーティー5.4が登場し、PCを直接操作するComputer Use機能が大きな注目を集めました。
さらに3月17日にはエージェント用の小型モデルmini/nanoまで追加されました。
2週間で3連発です。
ここでnote読者のみなさんに注目してほしいのは、5.3の改善ポイントが「文体」だったことです。
慇懃無礼な前置き。
説教臭い注意書き。
頼んでもいない箇条書きの連発。
いかにもエーアイっぽく、何かエーアイっぽさが鬱陶しい。
GeminiにもClaudeにも負けていました。
世界中のユーザーがうんざりしていたアレを、オープンエーアイはベンチマークスコアより優先して先に潰したんです。
モデルの賢さ競争から、製品としての使い心地競争に軸足を移したのです。
これが地味に効きました。
ここでシェアの低下速度が幾分マシになりました。
そして4月のジーピーティー5.5で、ついに転換が起きます。
オープンエーアイが公表したTerminal-Bench 2.0のスコアは82.7パーセント。
Claude Opus 4.7の69.4パーセントを上回ったのです。
Terminal-Benchというのは、端末上でエージェントとして実務をこなす能力を測るベンチマークです。
コーディング用途のベンチマークであるSWE-bench VerifiedではOpus 4.7が87.6パーセントでまだ先行していたものの、ブラウザ操作やファイル操作、ツール連携といった泥臭いエージェント業務での評価は確実に変わり始めました。
「Claudeのほうがコードが綺麗」が信仰と化していた開発者界隈で、「あれ、Codexで十分では？
」という声がぽつぽつ出始めたのがこの頃です。
ジーピーティー5.5登場によって、オープンエーアイの市場シェアは低下から再び上昇に向かいます。
とどめが7月9日のジーピーティー5.6です。
フラッグシップのSol、日常業務向けバランス型のTerra、最速低コストのLunaという3階層で投入され、コンテキストは100万トークンに拡大され、コンテキストサイズではGeminiと同等となりました。
8月にはSolの応答を最大14倍高速化するUltrafastモードも搭載されました。
「いや、ゆな先生。
新モデルなんてどこの会社も毎月出してるじゃないですか」
と思うみなさんもいるでしょう。
確かにその通りです。
オープンエーアイの動きで注目すべきは、出す速度ではなく捨てる速度のほうです。
ジーピーティー5.1は3月11日に提供終了。
ジーピーティー5.2は6月12日に終了。
ジーピーティー5は6月27日、o3も8月26日に退役しました。
出しては畳み、出しては畳み。
古いモデルをずるずる並べて客を迷わせるのではなく、最新世代に計算資源とユーザーを半ば強制的に寄せていくんです。
ゆな先生が過去記事で解説した、BYDの話を覚えているでしょうか。
10年乗る耐久消費財ではなく、2、3年で買い替えるスマホの感覚で車をかいはつする、あの異常なサイクルの話です。
あれと同じことが、いまエーアイモデルで起きているんです。
1年かけて大作を磨き上げようとして転んだ会社が、6週間ごとに改良版を投入してしじょうの反応で修正する会社に化けました。
どちらのスタイルが速く強くなるかは、火を見るより明らかです。
モデルの物量戦。
これが復権の第一因です。
だが、モデルだけでは10億人は戻ってきません。
製品とコストについて解説していきましょう。
## 復権の第二因は製品とコスト
モデルの次は、製品と金の話です。
こちらのほうが、生々しいです。
2026年7月9日、ジーピーティー5.6の公開と同時に、オープンエーアイはもう一つ、地味だが大きな変更を仕込んでいました。
それまで開発者向けに独立していたCodexのデスクトップアプリを廃止し、Chat、Work、Codexの3つを内包する新しいChatGPTデスクトップアプリへ統合したのです。
この構成、どこかで見覚えがないでしょうか。
そうです。
Claudeのデスクトップアプリです。
日本のエーアイ界隈でも、率直に言ってClaudeのアプリにかなり近い形になった、と評されていました。
つまり最大シェアを持つオープンエーアイは、プライドを捨てて、挑戦者の優れたせっけいを丸ごと取り込みにきたのです。
ゆな先生はこれを恥だとはまったく思いません。
むしろ、シェアを奪われた王者が取るべき教科書通りの一手です。
かつて日本のガラケーメーカーはiPhoneを鼻で笑い、自社の折りたたみ端末に固執して焼け野原になりました。
パクるべきときに全力でパクれる企業だけが生き残るのは、産業史の鉄則です。
新設のChatGPT Workも効きました。
Computer Use、内蔵ブラウザ、定期実行タスク、PowerPoint連携までを束ね、答えを作るエーアイから仕事を完了させるエーアイへと変貌したのです。
利用者のデータも面白いです。
オープンエーアイの6月の開示によれば、Codex利用者の約2割はエンジニアではないナレッジワーカーであり、その増加ペースはエンジニアの3倍以上だということです。
用途はレポートやスプレッドシート、契約書といった成果物づくりが中心ですが、そういう地味なブルシットジョブは世界には多いんです。
さらに6月末には、スマホから自宅PCのCodexを遠隔操作できるCodex Remoteまで一般提供されました。
コーディングツールだったはずのCodexが、いつの間にか事務職の残業を減らす道具になり、電車の中から仕事を指示するアプリにまでなっているのです。
コストの攻め方も変わりました。
1月には月8ドルの個人向け廉価プランGoが先行投入され、Go8ドル、Plus20ドル、Pro200ドルという階段状のライセンス構成が完成しました。
ユニクロがGUを出して価格帯の下を固めたのと同じ、下方展開です。
月8ドル、日本円で1,200円ほど。
飲み会1回より安いです。
「でもゆな先生、どうせ無料ユーザーのタダ乗りばかりで、大して金になってないんでしょ。
ゆな先生だって言ってたじゃん」
半分正しいが、半分間違いです。
確かにオープンエーアイの最大の問題点は、無料のライトユーザーが多いことにありました。
アンソロピックは金払いのいいエンジニアを大量に抱え、1人あたりのARPU（1人あたりの支払うお金）が桁違いに大きいです。
生成エーアイの問題点は、グーグル検索と違う広告を載せにくい、そして検索1回あたりのコストが非常に高く、赤字になりやすいという点にあります。
オープンエーアイに恋愛相談するフラッペ女子が増えても金にならないのです。
さいきんは有料サブスクリプションは5,000万件に達し、収益は改善し始めていると考えられます。
そして忘れてはならないのが、ライバルの敵失です。
6月16日、アンソロピックが開発者向けの重い使い方に対して従量課金的な仕組みを持ち込み始め、SNSは大炎上しました。
大量に使うと従量課金が自動的に走るというなかなかひどい変更でした。
Claude Codeを一日中回していたヘビーユーザーたちは、性能が追いつき消費トークンも少なくなったCodexへと、静かに移行し始めました。
さらに同じ6月には、最上位モデルMythos5とFable5の提供停止が長引きました。
極めつけは8月の騒動です。
Claude Codeの画面でジーピーティー5.6を動かしていた開発者のアカウントをアンソロピックが凍結してしまい、これを見たオープンエーアイ側のCodexを率いる人物が、ジーピーティー5.6 SolはClaude Codeの中でも動くと煽りながら、ChatGPT WorkとCodexの全有料ユーザーの利用上限をリセットするというパフォーマンスをしました。
かくして、8月6日の週間ユーザー10億人の発表に至るわけです。
シェアの数字だけ見れば5割を切ったままですが、エーアイ市場全体のパイが猛烈に膨張しているので、絶対数はまだ伸び続けています。
最大のエーアイアシスタントの座は、依然としてChatGPTのものです。
ただし、勘の良いみなさんのために一つ付け加えておきます。
ユーザー1人あたりの月間収益では、5月時点でClaudeの2.76ドルに対してChatGPTは1.74ドル。
単価では完全に負けています。
よって、月間収益でいうと、アンソロピック Claudeのほうが現在は上回っている可能性が高く、上場前の評価額もアンソロピックの方が高くなっています。
薄利多売の10億人をどうするのかというのは、オープンエーアイの大きな課題であり、金を払わない10億人の面倒をみるというのがどういうことなのか、もう少し理解してみましょう。
## 復権の裏にある推論コスト地獄
いつものエーアイのコスト構造という鉄則から見直してみましょう。
エーアイを開発し、そして提供し続けるためのコストは、大まかに以下の3つに集約されます。
いつもの3つです。
エーアイかいはつの技術者コスト。
半導体調達コスト。
電力コスト。
そして、春のアンソロピックの回で解説したことが、そのままオープンエーアイにも当てはまります。
数年前までは学習（Training）のほうが金を食っていたのですが、いまや完全に逆転し、ユーザーの質問に答えるたびに発生する推論（Inference）のコストが主役になりました。
考えてみれば当たり前の話です。
毎週10億人が使い、1日に25億件を超えるプロンプトが飛んでくるんです。
その1件1件の裏側で、データセンターの半導体がフル稼働し、電力を貪り食っているのです。
さっき、ChatGPTはユーザー単価でClaudeに負けている薄利多売だと述べました。
これを飲食店に例えるなら、ChatGPTは無料食べ放題バイキングです。
もしくはせいぜい客単価1,000円とか2,000円とかの食べ放題。
客が増えるのはめでたいです。
だが食べ放題だと、原価が客の食欲に正比例します。
しかもエーアイにおける客の食欲は年々増しているんです。
昔は一言二言の質問だったのが、いまや資料を丸ごと読ませ、コードを書かせ、エージェントに何十手順もの仕事をさせます。
1人あたりの食う量が、桁で増えているのです。
そこに重くのしかかるのが、諸君もよくご存知のNvidia税です。
粗利益率70パーセント超のジーピーユーを、何十万枚と積み上げなければ10億人の食欲は捌けません。
しかもオープンエーアイは、アンソロピックと同じ持たざる者です。
自前のデータセンターをほとんど持たず、マイクロソフトのAzureや他社のデータセンターを間借りしてここまで来ました。
2026年に入ってからはマイクロソフトとの独占的な関係を緩めてマルチクラウド化を進め、オラクルと組み、アマゾンからも出資と複数年のクラウド契約を取り付けています。
店を借り、厨房を借り、調理器具はNvidiaからプレ値で仕入れる。
売上の大半が大家と問屋に吸い上げられていくこの構造は、アンソロピックの回で説明した三つ星シェフの悲哀、そのものです。
だからこそオープンエーアイは、自前の厨房を建てるStargate計画をぶち上げました。
数年で約5,000億ドルを投じ、10ギガワット、つまり原発10基分に相当する計算容量を米国に自前で建設するという構想です。
狂気の沙汰です。
だが、現実はそう甘くありませんでした。
2026年2月頃には米主要メディアが計画の行き詰まりを報じ、2025年中に完了予定だった施設のうち完全稼働に至ったものは1件もなかったという厳しい指摘まで出ました。
ジーピーユーの供給不足と建設資材の遅延です。
結局5月には、見かねたマイクロソフトが運営に深く関与し始めたと報じられる始末でした。
そして、ここが今日いちばん重要なポイントです。
2026年上半期のオープンエーアイの停滞は、モデルが弱かったからだけではなく、計算能力そのものが足りなかったのです。
オープンエーアイの幹部自身が、上半期の計算リソース不足の具体的な原因の一つとして、ソフトウェア開発という単一のユースケースが突然プロダクト・マーケット・フィットを達成したことを挙げています。
要するに、Codexが売れすぎて計算資源を食い尽くし、他のサービスにしわ寄せがいっていたのです。
食べ放題の店で食べ物の在庫が切れるのは死活問題です。
他の客が離反してしまいます。
腹を空かせた10億人。
高すぎる仕入れ。
借り物の厨房。
この地獄の構造からの出口として用意されたのが、香辛料の名を持つ自社チップ、ハラペーニョでした。
## ハラペーニョとは何者か
さて、いよいよきょうの主役の登場です。
ハラペーニョの存在自体は2025年10月に予告されていました。
オープンエーアイがBroadcomと組み、10ギガワットきぼのカスタムアクセラレータ（=エーアイ専用半導体）を共同かいはつするという、あの巨大契約です。
そして2026年6月24日、両社はその第1弾となる推論特化型の独自エーアイ半導体、Jalapeño（ハラペーニョ）を正式発表しました。
命名の由来は明かされていませんが、ハラペーニョとは青唐辛子です。
グーグル ティーピーユーの対抗馬が唐辛子。
アンソロピックがMythos（神話）とかFable（寓話）とか、厨二病な名前をつけているところで、テキトーな名前をつけるのは当てつけなのでしょうか。
まず押さえるべきは、ハラペーニョはジーピーユーではないということです。
Nvidiaのジーピーユーが何でもこなせる汎用チップであるのに対し、ハラペーニョは特定用途向け集積回路、いわゆるASICであり、オープンエーアイはこれを知能プロセッサと呼んでいます。
狙いはただ一つ、エルエルエムの推論です。
学習は最初からやる気がありません。
料理人に例えるなら、ジーピーユーは1本で何でもこなせる高級万能包丁です。
いっぽうのハラペーニョは、刺身を引くことしかできない柳刃包丁です。
肉も野菜も切れませんが、刺身を引かせたら万能包丁では逆立ちしても敵いません。
そしてオープンエーアイの厨房では、注文の3分の2が刺身、つまり推論なのです。
驚くべきはその開発速度です。
TSMCの3nmプロセスを採用したハラペーニョは、設計開始からテープアウト、つまり設計完了までをわずか9ヶ月で駆け抜けました。
高性能ASICとしては記録的な速さです。
そしてその開発には、オープンエーアイ自身のエーアイモデルが直接投入されていました。
エーアイがエーアイチップをせっけいする時代が、しれっと始まっているのです。
しかも発表時点でサンプルASICはジーピーティー5.3-Codex-Sparkを含む実際のワークロードを実行しており、生産目標の周波数と電力で動いていました。
図面を発表したのではなく、動くモノを見せてきたんです。
そして8月25日、ハラペーニョを正式発表しました。
半導体調査会社SemiAnalysisのベンチマークであるInferenceXでの計測結果は、NvidiaのGB200およびGB300システムと比較して、電力あたりの仕事量で1.5倍から1.9倍、応答までのレイテンシは1.7分の1から3.6分の1。
対話型ワークロードに至っては2.1倍から4.1倍の優位という数字でした。
スループットとレイテンシは通常トレードオフの関係にあるのですが、ハラペーニョは一つのアーキテクチャで両方を取ったとオープンエーアイは主張していました。
面白いのはテストに使われたモデルです。
ジーピーティー-OSS-120Bに加えて、DeepSeek R1とKimi K2.5という中国勢のモデルまで走らせています。
自社モデル専用機ではなく、どのエルエルエムでも動く汎用推論マシンであるとアピールしたいわけです。
つまり他社でも採用できますよというわけです。
グーグルがティーピーユーを他社に売っているのと同じようなことが出来そうな雰囲気を出してきたわけで、グーグルへの当てつけであることは言うまでもありません。
ちなみにこのベンチマーク公開日は、Nvidiaの四半期決算発表のちょうど前日でした。
これも完全な当てつけです。
オープンエーアイの連中は結構性格が悪いのでしょうが、まあそこはどうでもよいです。
システム構成も見ておきましょう。
1キャビネットあたり128個のハラペーニョが収まり、キャビネット2つセットで160キロワット。
16ラックにまたがる2,048個のチップを一つのドメイン（=1つの仮想マシン）として接続できます。
そしてチップ同士を繋ぐ配線には、Nvidiaの独自規格InfiniBandではなく、Broadcomの最新スイッチとイーサネットが採用されました。
グーグルの回で解説したOCSほどの変態技術ではありませんが、思想は同じです。
チップ単体ではなく、ネットワークまで含めたシステム全体で、Nvidia経済圏の外に脱出するんです。
オープンエーアイはこれで従来のエーアイ ジーピーユー比およそ50パーセントの推論コスト削減を謳っており、超高級の吊るしのスーツを脱ぎ捨てて、オーダースーツを自前で仕立てる側に回ろうとしているのです。
ここまで聞くと、諸君はこう思うでしょう。
「もうNvidia要らないじゃん。
ハラペーニョ万歳」
だが、そうはいきません。
比較対象のBlackwellは現行世代であり、ハラペーニョが本格展開される頃には、NvidiaのRubinとAMDのMI455Xが2027年初頭から量産に入ってきます。
そして何より、チップは作ってからが本番なのです。
アンソロピックの回で、エーダブリューエスのTrainiumがグーグルのティーピーユーに数周遅れである理由を解説したのを覚えているでしょうか。
勝負を分けるのはカタログスペックではなく、ソフトウェア・エコシステムの完成度です。
## ハラペーニョは実質いつ本格稼働するのか
チップは作ってからが本番、という話から始めましょう。
いぜんの記事のアンソロピックの回で解説した通り、エーアイを半導体上で効率よく動かすには、エーアイモデルと半導体を繋ぐコンパイラやライブラリといったソフトウェア・エコシステムが不可欠です。
Nvidiaはかいはつしたことを何度も申し上げていますが、CUDAという環境を10年以上かけて磨き上げたからこそ帝国を築けたのであり、グーグルのティーピーユーも2015年の初代から実戦環境で鍛え続けて、ようやく今の完成度に達しました。
いっぽうでエーダブリューエスのTrainiumは、チップの紙のスペックは立派でも、この部分が未成熟であるがゆえに数周遅れと評されてきたわけです。
前章の例えを続けるなら、最高の柳刃包丁を手に入れても、研ぎ方を覚え、使い手が修行を積まなければ、刺身は引けません。
包丁を打つのが9ヶ月なら、修行は10年。
これが半導体業界の常識でした。
ならばハラペーニョも、本当に使い物になるのは2030年代なのか。
ゆな先生は、そうはならないと見ています。
オープンエーアイには、この修行期間を劇的に短縮できる、3つの近道があるからです。
第一に、オープンエーアイはソフトウェアの世界では新参者どころか、家元なのです。
諸君はTritonというソフトウェアをご存知でしょうか。
ジーピーユー向けのプログラムを書きやすくするオープンソースの言語で、いまや業界標準の一角なのですが、これを2021年に作って世に放ったのは、他ならぬオープンエーアイ自身です。
（元は大学のラボだったが、オープンエーアイが引き継いだ）
そしてハラペーニョ向けには、このTritonを土台にした自社のカーネル記述言語Gluonと、Teacupと呼ばれる自社製推論エンジンがすでに動いています。
何を言っているのかわかんないという人に簡単に言えば、Nvidiaのジーピーユーを効率よく使うには必須であるNvidiaのCUDAというツールがあるのですが、それと同じようなものをオープンエーアイも作って提供する、ということです。
第二に、修行をエーアイにやらせています。
オープンエーアイはCodexを使ってカーネル最適化を高速に回しており、2週間足らずでハラペーニョのスループットを2倍以上に引き上げ、わずか8日で並列構成をTP8からTP32へ拡張し（つまりエーアイのしょりを8チップで分散しょりする状態から、32チップで分散処理出来るようにした）、ラックをまたぐ展開まで到達してみせました。
人間のエンジニアが半年かける作業を、日の単位で回しているのです。
チップの設計にエーアイを使い、チップを動かすソフトの磨き込みにもエーアイを使うんです。
なかなか未来を感じますが、これが2026年の開発現場なのです。
そして第三に、これが最大の近道なのですが、客が自分しかいないことです。
CUDAは世界中の何百万人という開発者の、ゲームから科学計算まであらゆる要望に応える必要がありました。
だから10年かかったんです。
だがハラペーニョは外販しない自社専用インフラであり、ChatGPTとエーピーアイとCodexの裏側で、自社のモデルさえ完璧に動けばよいんです。
万人向けの教習所を建てるのと、自分ひとりが運転を覚えるのとでは、かかる時間が違うのは当然です。
「じゃあゆな先生、もうらいねんにはChatGPTは全部ハラペーニョで動くんですね」
というかというと、そうは行きません。
ソフトの修行は短縮できても、モノを作って並べる物理的な時間がかかるからです。
スケジュールを考えてみましょう。
オープンエーアイ自身の発表では、年内に自社インフラへの展開を開始するとしつつも、現在も大量生産準備とソフトウェアの成熟化を続けている段階です。
オープンエーアイのハードウェア責任者も2026年末の展開はごく少量で、意味のある規模になるのは2027年だと言っていました。
ゆな先生も「オープンエーアイが苦しい時期を迎えるのは2026年から2027年」といぜんからなんども言及しているのですが、自社半導体はすぐには展開は出来ないのです。
2027年前半に100メガワットを目指しているらしいのですが、原発0.1基分程度です。
Broadcomと契約した10ギガワットのわずか1パーセントです。
つまり2027年前半の時点ですら、ハラペーニョはまだ味見の段階で実用的と言える段階にはないんです。
だからオープンエーアイの収益にはあまり貢献しないとゆな先生は分析しています。
実質的な本格稼働、すなわちChatGPTのすいろんをハラペーニョが担う日はいつでしょうか。
ゆな先生の推定では、初代ではなく、2代目になると考えています。
グーグルのティーピーユーもver1, ver2, ver3とどんどん進化していきましたが、世代が進化するごとに対応できる処理も増えていきましたし、規模も拡大していきました。
初代で製造と運用の型を作り、改善点をすべて食わせた第二世代を2027年後半から2028年にかけて大量に並べるんです。
半導体の世界では、初代は授業料、2代目からが本番というのが相場なのです。
グーグルのティーピーユーも、外に誇れる代物になったのは第3世代以降でした。
よって結論、2026年末は試運転。
2027年は100メガワット級での実戦テストと増産準備。
そして実質的な主力化はGen2が量産に乗る2027年後半から2028年。
10ギガワットの契約が満了する2029年にかけて、すいろんの主役が段階的に唐辛子色に染まっていく。
これがゆな先生の見立てです。
なお、勘違いしてはいけないのは、これでNvidiaが用済みになるわけではないことです。
ハラペーニョは推論専用であり、モデルの学習には引き続き膨大なジーピーユーが要ります。
すいろんはしばらくNvidiaを使い続け、またハラペーニョも数が足りないので、段々と自社シリコンへ移すという使い分けを続けるでしょう。
そしてもう一つ、推論特化には固有のリスクもあります。
将来モデルのアーキテクチャが大きく変われば、特化型であるがゆえにチップごと陳腐化しかねないのです。
柳刃包丁は、客の注文が刺身である限りは無敵ですが、あしたから注文が全部ステーキに変わったら、ただの細長い鉄板になります。
## 投資家としてどう見るか
この構造変化で、誰の懐に金が落ちるのかです。
まず、ChatGPT復権の総括から。
シェア復活の正体は、6週間ごとのモデル物量戦と、ライバルの良いところを丸呑みした製品統合、そして月8ドルからのコスト競争でした。
冷静に見れば、これは薄利多売の10億人をさらに膨らませただけであり、儲かる体質になったわけではありません。
ARPUではClaudeに負け、推論コストは膨らみ続け、厨房は借り物のままです。
超ハイスペックを求めるユーザーはまだClaudeに残っています。
そのさいごのピースを埋めるのがハラペーニョであり、推論原価が半分になって初めて、食べ放題ビジネスに黒字化への道筋が見えてきます。
自社の格安農場で食料を作れるようになってこそ食べ放題ビジネスは成り立つんです。
ChatGPTの復権は、まだ前半戦が始まったところにすぎません。
後半戦の勝敗は2027年後半以降となります。
では投資家はどこを見るべきか。
ゆな先生の答えは、1年前の記事「Broadcomにビッグテックが群がる理由」からあまり変わりません。
まず、オープンエーアイの半導体開発で儲かるのはティーピーユーのときと同じで、Broadcomです。
グーグルのティーピーユーも、メタのMTIAも、そしてオープンエーアイのハラペーニョも、裏側にいるのはすべて同じBroadcomでした。
Broadcomは2027年にエーアイチップ売上1,000億ドルという目標を掲げ、業界初となる2nmプロセスでのカスタムチップ開発まですでに見据えています。
厨房を持っていなかったエーアイ企業たちに、次々と厨房を売りつける商人です。
この構図は当分崩れないとゆな先生は見ています。
ただし、Broadcomとの長年のパートナーシップを結んできたグーグルですが、ティーピーユーの調達が増えに増えてきたことから、Broadcomと協力してせっけいする分野をできるだけ最小化し、MediaTekとかMarvellなど、他の半導体設計企業と協力してティーピーユーをせっけいするようになり、Broadcomに支払う費用を最小化している様子です。
Broadcomの株価はさいきんは伸びが少ないのはこのためで、オープンエーアイによる自社半導体の成功でグーグル分をカバーできるかが正念場となります。
そして厨房をすべて製造しているのが、TSMCです。
Nvidiaのジーピーユーが売れてもTSMC、ハラペーニョが増えてもTSMC、グーグルが勝ってもTSMC。
誰が勝っても勝つ胴元です。
ではNvidiaは終わるのか。
おそらく終わりません。
学習には引き続きジーピーユーの巨大なじゅようがあり、2027年初頭には次世代のRubinが量産に控えています。
ただし、最大の顧客たちが次々と自前の柳刃包丁を打ち始めた以上、あの粗利益率70パーセント、すなわちNvidia税の税率だけは、長期的には切り下がっていく可能性もあるし、メモリも高くなってきています。
王座は当面安泰でも、ボロ儲けの黄金期は利益率という面ではじわじわと将来は下がっていく可能性が高いです。
ただ、その下がるペースより遥かに速くエーアイ半導体じゅようが高まるので、売上も利益もまだまだ拡大していくでしょう。
## 終わりに
ちなみにゆな先生は、この記事を書くにあたって輸入食材店で生のハラペーニョを買ってきて齧ってみました。
カルディで瓶詰めも売っているので買ってみてほしいです。
齧ってみたところ、辛いのですが、思ったほど辛くありませんでした。
ハラペーニョは唐辛子界ではかなりの温厚派で、辛さの単位で見るとハバネロの数十分の一しかないらしいです。
控えめな初代、本当に辛いのは次の世代から。
チップの世代論と妙に符合していて、一人で勝手に納得してしまいました。
将来の世代では、コードネームがハバネロになる日が来るのでしょうか。
グーグルが10年かけて完成させた垂直統合を、オープンエーアイはエーアイの力を借りて3年に圧縮しようとしています。
この無茶が成るのか、それともグーグルも苦労したソフトウェアライブラリの壁に跳ね返されるのか。
答え合わせは2027年、第二世代の量産と共にやってくります。
それまでは、Broadcomの受注残とオープンエーアイの調達ニュースを四半期ごとに眺めているのがいいでしょう。
この記事が諸君らのポートフォリオを見直す一つの視座となれば幸いです。
皆の投資の成功を祈ります。
ゆな先生より
スキする
コメントする
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。